des images comme celles-là on en voit
depuis plusieurs jours déjà ces dans la
foulée du mouvement antiraciste provoqué
dans avec la mort de georgia flake on
assiste donc un peu partout dans le
monde
c'est statut que ce fonds vandalisé
déboulonner des personnages historiques
qu'on avait voulu immortaliser jadis
mail on les voit avec nos yeux de 2020
et ça change la donne alors pour mieux
comprendre ce phénomène là mon invité ce
matin jonathan livernois professeur
d'histoire littéraire et intellectuelle
a dû verser et laval bonjour monsieur le
bernois
bonjour la croix en réalisant que que
ses statuts comme celle de christophe
colomb par exemple on ont mal vieilli
dans l'histoire c'est ça mais je te
phénomène tout à fait normal vous savez
dès l'antiquité chez les romains
notamment on avait ce qu'on appelle la
donation memoriae c'est à dire qu'on est
fait c est une personne est en disgrâce
on est face à son nom des édifices
publics et ont renversé également ses
statuts donc c'est un événement tout à
fait normal dans le cours de l'histoire
et je pense que la situation raciale
extrêmement tendu tout unis cristallise
sont actuellement tout simplement et
qu'on le voit assez bien par les
différents événements des derniers jours
par exemple ça nous fait voir parfois
des personnages qu'on a connu à travers
nos cours d'histoire d'une façon
complètement différente
christophe colomb qui était celui qui
avait découvert l'amérique c'est comme
ça qu'on l'enseigne encore aux enfants
dans les écoles primaires demande est ce
qu'on doit changer la façon aussi
d'enseigner l'histoire avec tout ce
qu'on ce qu'on vit présentement vous
savez l'histoire est un perpétuel
changement on lance un coup du tout la
même manière vous saviez wauquiez des
manuels d'histoire dans les années 60 50
au québec on enseignait les saints
martyrs canadiens les jésuites qui sont
brûlés par les amérindiens
ça change toujours et tant mieux et bien
ça c'est d'historiographie en comprend
bien comment ça peut changer mais cette
sensibilité là aussi elle doit intégrer
le cours de l'histoire la façon
d'enseigner l'histoire mais je vous
dirais qu ici une distinction affaires
importantes entre la commémoration et la
discipline historique
la commémoration ça appartient à
l'espace public
l espace à la société civile qui décide
finalement qu'elle veut honorer
quelqu'un où elle refuse de nommer
quelqu'un donne un exemple très simple à
montréal mais rue amherst par exemple
général britannique
bon là d
dès que l'on ne voulait plus rendre
hommage à ce général est plutôt rendre
hommage un chef émérite machette pardon
mais à un mot amérindiens à chateldon
qui veut dire donc une espèce de
communauté
donc la rue amherst a changé de nom ça
c'est la commémoration et l'historien
n'a pas en quelque sorte a qualifié ou à
décider ce qui doit être commémorée au
contraire il doit enregistrer les
variations comprendre si vous voulez
proposer une saisie des savoirs et des
sensibilités d'un temps particulier donc
c'est un peu le rôle de l'historien et
on voit qu actuellement il ya une belle
matière pour les historiens c'est très
clair ouais est ce que est ce que la
façon dont on voit nos monuments
historiques nos statuts doit changer
parce que souvent dit ben c'est la cc
pour immortaliser une partie de
l'histoire mais en fait ça s'arrête
quand c'est ce que vous nous dites oui
certains ça change et c'est au fond
déboulonné une statue c'est pas tant
joué contre l'histoire c'est faire
l'histoire changé dénonce c'est normal
ça se fait toujours en exemple très
simple à paris par exemple il ya un
endroit qui s'appelle la place qui
s'appelait de la place où 15 qui devenue
la place de la révolution on note
guillaume tinelli roi le roi et la reine
notamment et c'est devenu plus tard a
donc voulu plus facile passé c'est
devenu la place de la concorde c'est
donc on connaît actuellement
alors c'est normal ça participe du temps
l'historien doit rendre compte
mais ce n'est donc pas par la
commémoration pour faire l'histoire je
vous dis faut défaire plus d'exemples
sévèrement il ya une pétition qui
circule en ce moment concernant la
statue de james magill sur le parterre
de l'université mcgill je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu passer mais déjà
plusieurs noms des gens qui réclament
qu'on enlève cette statue lait qu'on la
remplace par un arbre par exemple est
intéressant dans le code geass miguil
j'imagine pourrait faire à son passé
donc de propriétaires d'esclaves
lorsque o'shea la chose qui est plus
complexe à ce moment là c'est que c'est
l'université miguil donc c'est sur le
terrain de l'université mcgill ça
appartient donc à cette institution
c'est plus difficile évidemment c'est
gérer l'espace commence à dépasser qui
propriétaire d'un statut comment ça
fonctionne mais on peut très bien posé
la question et on peut très bien et et
roger d'université mais qu'il de ce
point de vue et elle
un rôle à jouer comme comme membre comme
partie prenante de la société donc faire
attention avec ça et aussi certaines
situations entre rapidement ou le défi
où on peut se tromper
je donne un exemple à montréal d'une
avenue de rome dans ce quartier ville
l'avenue de ram ce n'est pas pour rendre
hommage à leur dieu rama l'auteur du
fameux rapport
c'est une référence vraisemblable à la
ville anglaise de durham
donc on veut est-ce que qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ça plusieurs
voulaient changer le nom mais certains
disent bien attention c'est la ville ces
propos lors durable donc il y aussi une
précaution à prendre faut pas s'emballer
trop aller trop vite réfléchir mais
quand même posé des gestes et puis une
université mcgill aura réfléchi
évidemment au passé de son fondateur ça
nous ramène à nos livres d'histoire et
c'est pour ça que les profs d'histoire
sont là tout comme vous mais c'est une
véranda merci beaucoup pour vos lumières
au revoir